i want to bring in bret baer to give us
a look now this overview as he's been
tracking the latest developments on
ukraine he's back at the big map hey
brett
all right let's take a look at what
we're seeing in ukraine over the past 24
36 hours we're seeing incremental
movement by russian forces as we've seen
more movement towards key from a number
of different areas a little movement out
here in kharkiv but we're seeing
bombardment in a number of different
cities
especially around kyiv in the suburbs as
the russians continue to do this a
bombardment from the outside before
encircling a city
we haven't seen full encircling yet in
many places including odessa which we
were expecting
more of a run at that by russian forces
but it hasn't happened yet as you look
closer to keeve you can see
kind of these
these fingers coming down these are
russian force and forces moving
and they are getting supplied from
belarus
with
food and fuel
but the main
effort is this bombardment into
submission which we've seen around the
country this is a closer look at kiev if
you look at this right here this is
downtown and sort of these blobs are
russian forces intruding but they are
seeing a lot of ukrainian defense and a
lot of pushback by ukrainian forces in
fact thousands and thousands of russian
soldiers including
according to u.s intelligence have
already
died in this conflict and that is taking
its toll we've talked a little bit about
the nuclear facilities chernobyl up here
in the north
cut off to electricity there was some
concern that the heat could build up
there and radioactivity could leak out
radiation rather
it hasn't happened iaea says they're
convinced and nuclear experts do the
russians are controlling this particular
facility but you can see there are a
number of different reactors throughout
the country
that are of concern during a conflict
like this in the south the most activity
that we've seen is up here in mario pole
where we've seen those horrific
bombardments including that maternity
hospital that we saw earlier today some
movement by russian forces this way we
expect it's going to eventually go down
to the port city of odessa but this so
far has not been touched there has not
been this landing that we suspected to
take the port city as of yet but the
people in odessa we've seen video of
them barricading and building up and
training getting ready for a big fight
there ukrainian forces holding
very steady on this mario pole
june 21st this is a shopping center cars
parked out here a grocery store
all just like you would see in any u.s
city
but the bombardment has been
intense and there you see
the reaction or the aftermath
this shopping center taken out
by either a cruise missile or a bomb
as well as this grocery store these are
just a few miles from that maternity
hospital that we saw hit
in that hospital amazingly only 17
people
injured no one died
but the deaths are ticking up civilians
military and russian military as this
insurgency looks like it's going to last
for quite some time
keep tracking it chan send it back to
you all right we'll check back with you
in just minutes brett thank you very
much hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else